so mark said was resignation as national
security adviser over the weekend wasn't
a complete surprise David Frost's
appointment as his successor though was
mark said well is a veteran Sakura
Kratts he was Britain's ambassador in
Afghanistan a former UN weapons
inspector and the permanent secretary of
the Home Office he worked closely there
and in Downing Street with Teresa may
his old boss isn't happy I served on the
National Security Council for nine years
six years as Home Secretary and three as
Prime Minister during that time I
listened to the expert independent
advice from national security advisors
on Saturday my right honourable friend
said we must be able to promote those
with proven expertise why then is the
new National Security Advisor
a political appointee with no proven
expertise in national security we have
had previous national security advisors
all of them excellent not all of them
necessarily people who were steeped in
the security world some of whom were
distinguished diplomats in their own
right
so David sorry David Frost is a
distinguished diplomat in his own right
and it is entirely appropriate that the
prime minister of the day should choose
an adviser appropriate to the needs of
the Allan David Frost is currently the
government's chief brexit negotiator he
is an experienced diplomat but has no
meaningful track record in national
security matters David Frost comes to
this role as a experienced diplomat but
with very little experience of the whole
world of defense intelligence security
policing I am worried that he doesn't
have the experience in his background
that he should have for a job like this
the UK faces threats from terror groups
like Islamic state and al-qaeda state
actors like Russia China and Iran and
internal threats from the far right and
dissident republicanism
Frost won't be the only new face at the
top of British security mi5 has recently
got a new director general and the next
chief of mi6 will be appointed in the
coming months David Frost will be busy
in his new job alistair bungle Sky News